Next year, our parent company, Sharp Corporation of Japan, will celebrate...
...its 100th year anniversary.
And in preparation for this milestone, we have set two business visions:...
...the first is, contribute to the world with an environment and health conscious business,...
...focusing on energy saving and energy creating products.
You have been hearing this message from Sharp for several years now...
...and we take this very, very seriously.
Achieving goals takes time and focus.
You will see the result of this focus in almost all the products we sell today.
For example, Sharp is a world leader in solar energy which creates green renewable power.
And most of the products we create are among the most energy efficient in their categories.
Our second vision is to contribute to ubiquitous society with one of a kind LCDs.
What we mean is that, we are increasingly connecting to each other through digital devices,...
...and Sharp LCDs serve as the windows and remote control for our digital lives.
Sharp has always been at the forefront of LCD technology...
...and we continue to invest in the future of LCD.
For example, last November, we had a privilege of installing a 3x3 Sharp video wall,...
...like the one behind me, in the windows of the 9/11 memorial preview site in New York City.
The public display is visible from the street and features rendering of the memorial and museum...
...and the official 9/11 memorial opening day counter.
So you see, Sharp is already a window to the connected world...
...and this trend is just beginning.